[Música]
las mujeres del mundo se unieron en un
solo reclamo para lograr la igualdad de
derechos y condiciones laborales entre
otros pedidos todo esto en el marco de
la conmemoración del día internacional
de la mujer en México las mujeres de
minorías pidieron ser visibilizadas en
el mundo musulmán marcharon en las
calles pese a la posibilidad de la
represión
en Estados Unidos el departamento de
Justicia presentó un informe en el que
responsabiliza a la policía de la ciudad
de Louisville de ejercer violencia
sistemática contra la población
afroamericana esto tiene lugar dos años
después de las investigaciones debido a
la muerte de brionan
y mercenarios del grupo Wagner cierran
el cerco en la ciudad de bahamut su
líder afirmó que sus tropas tienen el
control del este de la ciudad desde la
otan indicaron que debido al avance de
los rusos bahmud podría caer en control
de sus manos en los próximos días pese a
los esfuerzos y resistencia de las
tropas ucranianas
muy buenas noches Bienvenidos a las
noticias de France 24 soy Santiago López
González Gracias por estar con nosotros
hasta ahora vamos a comenzar en México
en donde en medio de gritos pancartas y
pañoletas moradas miles de mujeres
marcharon por la emblemática avenida
Paseo de la Reforma en el centro de la
capital mexicana para conmemorar el Día
Internacional de la mujer que sirvió
para reclamar a las autoridades de ese
país de ese país por las altas tasas de
feminicidios que aquejan a México las
manifestantes algunas de ellas
representantes de minorías y también
grupos históricamente discriminados
pidieron visibilidad también pacientes
oncológicas se unieron como grupo para
ser parte de esta marcha del 8m desde
Ciudad de México marinas ardiña nos
cuenta más detalles de esta jornada bajo
un sol
impone miles
de mujeres en Ciudad de México en el Día
Internacional de la mujer para
reivindicar entre otras cosas el cc de
las múltiples violencias que sufren a
diario cada dos horas una mujer es
asesinada en México 2022 cumplió el
trágico récord de más de 3.700
homicidios de mujeres sin embargo solo
el 33,7% de estos asesinatos son
investigados como feminicidios y más del
90% quedan en la impunidad Pese a que
cada día en México diez mujeres son
asesinadas por el mero hecho de ser
mujer
Yo vengo porque soy sobreviviente de
feminicidio y pido justicia para que me
agresor tenga una condena ejemplar y las
carpetas se arreglan como deben de ser
para que él pague lo que hizo las
reivindicaciones en esta jornada son
extensas las manifestantes también salen
a las calles por la paridad
institucional laboral y económica La
Brecha salarial entre mujeres y hombres
en México es del 34% más datos el 98% de
las mexicanas han sufrido acoso y
hostigamiento en el transporte público y
México es el segundo país de América
Latina con peor inserción laboral para
las mujeres salimos a marchar por todas
las compañeras que estamos representando
a la científicas porque siempre dicen
que las feministas con aquellas que
están en la ciencia o en la academia
justamente porque queremos hacer una
ciencia y una academia diferente
queremos hacer una academia En donde ya
no se replican estas prácticas machistas
Y en donde todas estemos incluidas el
gobierno mexicano ha desplegado más 800
policías mujeres también ha blindado
edificios y estatuas mientras que aquí
en las calles de México las mujeres
compartas arengas y cánticos han vuelto
a teñir las calles del color de las
Jacarandas y también en varios países
del Mundo musulmán las mujeres salieron
a las calles a pesar de los riesgos de
represión y la intimidación que ejercen
allí los gobiernos en Turquía Pakistán
Afganistán solo por mencionar algunos
las mujeres decidieron marchar por sus
derechos
en Turquía a pesar de la prohibición de
marchar en muchas partes del país miles
de mujeres se reunieron en Estambul las
manifestantes tuvieron que esquivar la
policía que mantenía cerrados los
accesos a la famosa Plaza taxin
venimos aquí para mostrar nuestra rabia
contra el estado y para mostrar su
irresponsabilidad con respecto al
feminicidio También estamos aquí juntas
por las personas que perdimos a causa
del terremoto El feminicidio y los
asesinatos de transexuales
en Pakistán miles marcharon en las
principales ciudades en contra de la
violencia de género pese a los intentos
de las autoridades por impedir estas
reuniones
para mí el derecho que debería estar en
primer lugar es el derecho a elegir
deberíamos tener derecho a tomar
nuestras propias decisiones ya sea el
matrimonio el divorcio la elección de
una carrera la decisión de estudiar o
cualquier otra decisión en nuestras
vidas estoy aquí para todos estos
derechos en este país las marchas son
criticadas por promover los valores
liberales occidentales e ir en contra de
la religión algunos temas como el
divorcio el acoso sexual o la
menstruación siguen siendo tabú mientras
que en kabul unas 20 mujeres salieron a
las calles y desafiaron el régimen de
los talibanes el día anterior varias
mujeres se habían reunido a puertas
cerrada para reclamar el regreso de sus
derechos y la reapertura de las escuelas
para las jóvenes
sin quedarnos en casa nos lleva al cielo
Entonces no quiero ir allí mientras
creen tantas restricciones sobre que
llevar y cómo llevarlo si un hombre que
te mira no debe sentirse tentado
Entonces porque los hombres no se cubren
los ojos según las Naciones Unidas desde
el regreso del régimen talibán
Afganistán es el país más represivo del
mundo hacia las mujeres
cambiamos de tema Vamos hasta Estados
Unidos allí el departamento de Justicia
presentó un informe que responsabiliza a
la policía de la ciudad de Louisville de
ejercer violencia sistemática contra la
población afroamericana este reporte
tiene lugar dos años después de una
larga investigación por el asesinato de
la ciudadana Taylor
un pronunciamiento sin precedentes por
parte del departamento de Justicia
Estados Unidos
el departamento ha concluido que existe
una causa razonable para creer que en
lushville metro y la policía
metropolitana se involucraron en un
patrón o práctica de conducta que viola
la primera y cuarta enmienda de la
Constitución
Esta es la principal conclusión de las
autoridades tras Investigar los hechos
detrás de la muerte de la joven
afroamericana briona Taylor asesinada
por la policía durante una redada el 13
de marzo de 2020 el departamento de
Justicia es Claro en señalar que las
actuaciones de la policía son
sistemáticamente discriminatorias contra
la población afroamericana estos
hallazgos justificaron la decisión Del
fiscal general de poner fin a las
restricciones sobre los decretos de
consentimiento que impedían
responsabilizar a los departamentos de
Justicia locales ahora la fiscalía
general estadounidense se sentará a
negociar con la fiscalía y la policía de
Luis vil un acuerdo de consentimiento
este acuerdo con promedio a la ciudad y
a la fiscalía de Louisville a trabajar
con la fiscalía general la comunidad Los
oficiales de la policía y otras partes
interesadas para abordar los problemas
que hemos identificado
la eventual firma de este consentimiento
entre autoridades locales y federales es
un paso importante para combatir la
violencia policial sistemática en
Estados Unidos contra la población negra
y una esperanza para que casos como el
de briona Taylor George Floyd y decenas
más no se repitan
nos vamos ahora hasta Ucrania en donde
se mantienen muy fuertes los combates
para conquistar la ciudad de Back mood
por lo que el cerco se ha ido cerrando
en las últimas horas el jefe del grupo
mercenarion y prey washing afirmó que
sus tropas ya controlan el este de la
ciudad esta El Avance ruso que el
secretario general de la otan James
Indicó que no descarta que los rusos
dominen la urbe en la región de
donnieves en los próximos días
la advertencia fue lanzada por el jefe
de la otan bahamut podría caer en manos
del ejército Ruso y del grupo
paramilitar Wagner en los próximos días
no podemos excluir que bakmuk caiga
finalmente en los próximos días es
importante subrayar que esto no refleja
necesariamente un punto de inflexión en
la guerra Solo subraya que no hay que
subestimar a Rusia estas declaraciones
llegan horas después de que llegue
del grupo paramili afirmara que sus
hombres han capturado toda la zona este
de la ciudad
corregimientos del grupo Wagner han
tomado todo el este debate del río
bacmut está totalmente controlado por el
grupo Wagner se puede informar de esto
y es que ante el temor de que la caída
debajo deje vía libre a los rusos para
apoderarse de otras ciudades del este de
Ucrania el presidente
espera la entrega inminente de nuevas
armas occidentales ha dejado Claro en
una entrevista con CNN que su ejército
No cederá ni un centímetro de la ciudad
las preocupaciones de selensky sobre los
avances rusos parecen fundados
Moscú dice que la captura de bajo t es
necesaria para la continuación de su
ofensiva en las últimas semanas los
soldados rusos han realizado pequeños
avances y ahora parecen controlar el
acceso a la ciudad por el norte el sur y
el este creando La amenaza de un cerco
Aunque se cuestiona el valor estratégico
de la ciudad ha adquirido una innegable
importancia simbólica como resultado de
los esfuerzos de ambos bandos desde el
verano pasado para controlarla es todo
por el momento aquí en las noticias de
France 24 más información en las redes
sociales y en la página web France
24.com siga con nosotros buenas noches
[Música]